I'm reacting to another video from home
math on Tick Tock and
and YouTube so whole math is an account
that really does a good job of making
visual representations of the dating
market so it's interesting I've seen
like Sim like obviously in the
manosphere we've seen similar stuff like
this for years but he does such a good
job of describing the female experience
I was just really really impressed so he
has this series where he just interprets
like things women say on Tick Tock so
why don't we pull up the click clip of
the standard female delusion chart for
dating this is the standard female
delusion chart it is a tool for bringing
balance back to the dating Market the
standard female delusion chart is
replacing the old chart because there
was some confusion here's how the chart
works we all know that only a few people
are very dumb most people are average
and a few people are very smart this
creates a shape called a bell curve it
works the same way with other traits
like height and attractiveness most
people are average I received a lot of
constructive feedback about the old
chart I was told that men and women
match up evenly but that's only true in
long-term relationships so this is how a
woman would see men that she knows maybe
25 men at most the other 4 billion men
however she would see like this as you
can see most of us are disgusting and if
you are a male three or below you're
this cute little ghost
so generally speaking men rate women on
a bell curve and women rate men on a
jezebel curve and of course it's true
that some men underrate women but other
men overrate women and they are people
so it balances out
on the other hand women rate men they do
not know as 80 percent garbage this
model is supported by data from every
dating app by going outside and
listening to women when they talk it
depends on what he looks like probably
based on someone's personality you could
really hit it off with someone but
attractiveness is a big player of it
that sounded very shallow and by being
attractive if you are a man who has
moved past this line you'll know what I
mean the standard female delusion chart
can help keep women out of the sleeper
Zone where they languish in emotional
neglect waiting for commitment that was
never coming it works by correcting
ludicrous female perceptions like this
let's go through the chart piece by
piece you can pause on each one to let
them sink in this is how men see women
normal this is how women see men brutal
this is how women see themselves
delusional and this is how women rate
other women publicly everyone's a 10 and
privately
I'll go into more detail in an upcoming
video on YouTube for now feel free to
take a screenshot and use the chart
yourself just make sure to credit me or
I will sue I'm also creating a
comprehensive rating system to help
everyone know their level once you know
your score just use this equalized chart
to find your match so assuming standard
female delusion a female 6 matches with
a male she sees as 3.8 a female 8
matches with a male she sees as 6.5 and
a female 2 probably has Hobbies or an
adorable fur baby
the standard female delusion chart can
go a long way towards correcting female
Ridiculousness but only if you're honest
if the standard female delusion chart
makes you mad stay mad forever it's
great for the algorithm I'll be back
soon with instructions for giving a fair
rating until then good luck
you like being approached in public by
guys it depends on what he looks like
probably like to be defined below
average hey like
just look around
no I own your place so the next one is
how women get stuck on their highest
setting foreign
tell me that men go back to their exes
too and that's true but this video is
demonstrating what men do not do women
get stuck on their highest setting once
she's been with this guy all of these
guys look like that men on the other
hand when we lose you and we look for
someone else we do this and this and
this so what I thought was interesting
about this video was it really does show
the problem in the dating market so
again women were never happy we always
want better and better and better and
you see this because they've given us
all these rights and we whine more and
more and more and you can see it in the
dating Market because really
um women date out of their league all
the time we're all of us probably would
have been thrown out a hundred years ago
so whole math what he's really doing is
showing the problem with the dating
Market you know now all right so there's
always been the peasants and the Kings
right and the peasants knew if the king
came in town he could just steal her
like this isn't new information
that the king wants your wife she's gone
NADA he's just gonna you know there used
to be the two tribes they would fight it
out and if if your husband died boom
they killed the kids killed your husband
now you're part you're with this guy
that's that's just our nature it's not
very loyal sorry guys
um and so the problem is today now we
have average women that have access to
really the modern version of Kings top
one five ten percent men and it's not
like women you know we go in you know
thinking oh this is a top 10 men we we
think they're on our level because
that's that's who's given us attention
and the problem is that's why we have
this extreme delusion where we all think
we're hotter than we are I don't you
know what's funny I've been asking for
ratings on the shows for a year and a
half now I don't think any chick has
rated herself below average
ever yeah let that sink in every chick
thinks she's above average I think the
lowest rating I've maybe gotten was a
five
I've never had a four three two or one
even from extremely obese women or
they're clearly below average but yeah I
I'm a really big fan of whole math I
think he's hilarious
um and I think he does a good job of
explaining this into a way women could
really like take it because again I I've
seen stuff like this before but he does
a really good job of making it like easy
for the women to understand so last but
not least today I'm gonna bring up a
clip from Kevin Samuels Kevin Samuels is
really the goat of YouTube I
I freaking loved Kevin Samuels like I
used to watch his live streams all the
time when I was younger
but I really think it's a shame I I
genuinely think he's a guy that was gone
way too soon like I I think it's such a
tragedy that he died as young as he did
and this is a common Trope that I I hear
and I see from women on the show I'm
single by choice and again you know
really single by choice just means that
the men you want don't want you because
no woman is gonna say no to a guy that's
six pack six figures six inches so you
know it's like either you're shooting a
little too high and maybe you gotta
shoot lower
um or you know maybe you got to improve
maybe you got to lose weight maybe you
gotta you know fix your hair or you know
maybe you gotta become a better person
um all of these things
but the problem is simps and other women
have allowed us to just say these
phrases that don't make sense so here's
Kevin Samuel's take on single by choice
you're not single by choice
your choices are made you single but
yeah I was on Tick Tock and I just saw
that came up come up and it made me so
sad because I'm like I loved Kevin
Samuels and you could see how many
one-on-ones he did with women just by
the way he spoke and talked about
patterns in society
um he yeah there's no such thing as
single by choice it's either
the the man you want don't want you and
you have to improve or lower your
standards and the funny thing is men
know this innately like if you tell a
guy
um that in order to get you know an
eight or higher he's got to make a lot
of money he's got to be in good shape
he's got to do all these things that
women like
the men are the men are like yeah
duh
and if you say you know you have to be
above a certain level in order to get
submission from a chick the man will
kind of say
yeah
obviously
um but the women on the other hand it's
so crazy when you say you're an average
chick and to get an above average result
you got to improve this is like
you it's like craziness
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video on your
way out and guys seriously get a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today the link to
that is in the description please like
the video on your way out let's get this
to a thousand likes subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time